It's great to welcome back to the program,
Michael Moss, New York Times best selling
author, wrote the book Salt, Sugar, Fat.
New book out today is Hooked Food Free Will
and How the Food Giants Exploit Our Addictions.
So great to have you back, Michael.
Hey, nice to see you again, David.
So in the time since we last spoke, we've
learned a lot more about the sort of physically
addictive nature of certain food elements.
We've learned about sugar.
We've we've learned about other elements,
but we've also learned a lot about food marketing,
nutritionism and so many other aspects that
that operate on a more sort of psychological
rather than physical level.
Talk a little bit about sort of your general
approach to this book and what you're talking
about when you talk about addiction to food.
Yeah, so, I mean, I wrote the book and I started
researching it because right up the salt,
sugar, fat came out at the end of it, I was
trying to be a little optimistic and say,
look, ultimately we're the ones who decide
what to eat and how much.
In the very first question I got was, but
Michael, isn't the stuff you're writing about
addictive like drugs?
And if so, how can we have any control over?
And I was like, whoa, what do you mean?
You're comparing like Twinkies to heroin?
I mean, I was like, no way.
But I came full circle in realizing and talking
to experts who coached me on this, which is
that, look, in some ways food is even more
addictive than some drugs.
And part of the reason for that is that the
companies have figured out ways to tap into
exploit, if you will, our basic instincts.
I mean, we by nature are drawn not just to
eat, but to overeat.
And the companies have figured that out and
turned that, which was a good thing for most
of our existence into a really treacherous
thing.
By making over eating an everyday thing is
what is the start of the chain of all of this?
Is it profit motive for food giants?
You know, I mean, look, I still don't see
this as an evil empire that intentionally
set out to to make us overweight or otherwise.
These are companies doing what all companies
want to do, make as much money as possible
by selling this product as possible and by
making that product as attractive and irresistible
as as possible.
So they have chemists working for them who
have marketing experts, psychologists, sort
of all trained and focused on hitting our
biological instincts, but also our emotional
buttons to maximize the allure of their products.
Can you talk a little bit about what what
exactly is it when you researched this, that
that is most addictive?
Is it is sometimes said, you know, the dopamine
release from sugar is similar to drugs.
Is it what exactly is it?
Yeah, so there's a few things.
One, we are built to sort of love food that's
inexpensive.
It kind of makes sense, right?
The least put out the least amount of energy
for the calories that you're getting.
You know, the industry uses these chemical
labs to come up with new formulations that
are shaving, you know, 10 cents, 20 cents
off the price of a package that excite the
brain.
They're really good at variety.
You know, we're we, by instinct are drawn
toward different kinds of food.
That's why we're able to populate different
parts of the world with different food to
eat.
And we're really good at adjusting to that.
You know, you walk in the cereal aisle of
the grocery store, there are two hundred versions
of sugar is charged with that sole purpose
of exciting the brand.
We love calories, right.
We have sensors in our gut, also possibly
in our mouth that detect calories in food.
And so the food companies have been really
good about packing in the calories.
I mean, compare like a hot pocket to a stick
of celery and you get the idea of the contrast
between basic foodstuffs and ultra processed
foods.
And again, the brain the brain gets really
excited by the more calories and is much more
apt to sort of put you into that impulsive
compulsive drive.
We're the thinking part of your brain doesn't
have a chance to step up and say, wait a minute,
Michael, I think you're going too hard on
this food.
It seems that at a certain point there was
a huge evolutionary evolutionary advantage
to that in the sense that, like, if you think
back to Hunter gathering and the amount of
time and energy spent chewing in order to
obtain a certain number of calories, and then
all of a sudden you may be able to, you know,
you cook something and you're so which allows
you to kind of do in advance some of the work
that your teeth and body would do.
The body probably would sense that, wow, one
bite of this is conferring way more calories.
And it was good at a certain point.
It was such an eye opener to me, spending
time with evolutionary biologists, one of
whom kind of pointed out to me, look, Michael,
it's not so much that food is addictive.
It's that we by nature are drawn to eating
and the companies have changed the nature
of our food.
You know, you said it absolutely body fat
was a really good thing.
It enabled our brains to grow, enable us to
get through hard time.
They've allowed us to have more babies, which
are natural selection is all about.
And it's only in the last 50 years that we're
sort of realizing that having too much body
fat will work against you.
I have no idea.
But body fat is a living thinking organ.
And when you try to reduce.
About on your body, it will fight back an
incredibly diabolical ways, it will send signals
to the brain that you're hungry when you're
not hungry, it will slow down your metabolism.
It will make you get more excited when you
see advertising for processed food and cause
you to want that food more than you did before
you had that extra weight.
One of the things that Michael Pollan writes
about in Omnivore's Dilemma is the sort of
transformation by food companies of foods
into food products, taking, for example, the
idea of like if you just take corn, it's tough
to make a lot more money just selling corn.
Maybe you can get a seed that can be planted
more densely so you can sort of like up how
much you can grow in an acre.
But like selling corn as corn is only going
to get you so far.
However, if you take corn, break it down into
its component parts.
You can now use corn sirup as a as an alternative
to sugar.
You're adding calories and reducing cost and
you're extracting and taking all these different
elements.
Most people, if they looked at a list of ingredients,
would recognize a lot of that stuff is highly
processed and probably not that good for you.
And yet these products are all incredibly
popular.
So.
So what are food companies doing in order
to make people want products that if you're
really presented with the ingredient list,
most people probably know aren't really the
best things to be eating?
Yeah, I think one of the most important things
they're doing is speed.
I learned from researchers who study drug
addiction, whether it's cigarets, alcohol
or heart or narcotics, that the hallmark of
addiction is how fast the substance hits the
brain, because the faster it gets in our brain,
the more apt we are to hit that go button
and not respond to the smaller part of the
brain that's trying to put the brakes on,
you know, us doing something we really don't
want to be doing.
And so the food companies were ingenious in
building speed into their product, both in
the factory to reduce the cost, but also just
the way we eat it.
And I often refer to these foods as convenience
foods because a lot of them could be eaten
with one hand while you're doing something
else.
And that creates this mindless this mode where
you're not paying attention to the food and
when you're not paying attention to their
products, they're controlling you rather than
you controlling them.
The speed is speed is probably the most important
and most diabolical aspect of these ultra
processed foods.
How does all of this apply to the sort of
diets sometimes sometimes called fad diets,
lifestyle diets that sometimes will come in
and out of favor in large part because of
marketing, when it seems that over time, if
you take a big picture view, you don't really
seem to need anything so specialized that
seems that sort of limiting processed foods
is a good thing.
Generally limiting, but not necessarily completely
eliminating animal products isn't a bad thing
to me.
I see profit opportunities.
Any time you see a diet that requires a lot
of one thing or none of another is my my instinct
right on that.
Well, absolutely.
And let me tell you about sort of profit.
I was stunned to learn that the largest processed
food manufacturers quietly bought up gain
control over some of our more popular dieting
methods.
And we're talking about Hynde's buying Weight
Watchers, Slim Fast, Atkins, you name it,
South Beach Diet.
A lot of these brands and methods were acquired
none other than by the food companies.
And then they kind of populated the grocery
store with diet versions of their mainline
products, which really weren't all that different
then to full bore calorie version, sitting
next to each other on the shelf and sort of
counting on us to be making rational decisions
every time we go shopping as to which of these
products to to to to buy and eat and pay attention
to.
But here's the thing again, that sort of relates
to that relates to addiction.
The thing about that and one of the lessons
from drug addiction, one of the things that
makes these food products even more troublesome
than drugs can be, which is that you can't
just go cold turkey.
You can't just stop eating to deal with a
food eating problem.
We all have to eat.
And that's the slippery slope.
And so we walk into the grocery store and
we're so vulnerable at times in our lives
or times of the day to their marketing and
their products and these diet schemes that
look.
By and large, work until they stop working,
which is why so many people have trouble sticking
to a diet, because it's strange and it's different,
and ultimately because the power of memory
and is keeping our eating habits draws us
back to what we were doing before is the most
people most people are busy, people are working,
people are earning a living.
They have to get their kids back and forth.
It can be very difficult to keep up with.
Is the egg good or bad right now?
Is coffee good or bad?
Is soy good about that?
Is there one principle which is just avoid
processed foods as much as possible?
That is the simplest thing for people to remember.
Or would it be something else?
I think it kind of depends where you are on
the spectrum.
Look, I wrote this book for everybody.
Whether you're in an eating disorder with
bingeing or you've got clinical obesity or
you're at the other end where you're just
kind of like troubled by, like, how much attention
you have to pay to food to stay on top of
it and not let it like, you know, gain control
of your of your life.
And I think the overall lesson I think, again,
a lesson learned from the drug addiction world
is that it really helps to have a plan no
matter what it is, but to have that plan and
then execute it.
So, you know, if you're hit by the proverbial
3:00 p.m. craving for a cookie, what you learn
from people who've helped people deal with
drug addiction is you've got to like it, 255.
You need to be working on your your plan,
whether that involves getting up and stretching
or calling a friend or having an alternative
snack like a handful of nuts in order to ward
off that craving grief, because those cravings
come on so fast that no amount of willpower
is going to help you resist them once they
hit the reward center of the brain so that
that priest thought, no matter what kind of
what your strategy is, I think is the overall
lesson I learned in talking to the other two
addiction researchers in terms of now all
of the sugar alternatives, you know, sweetened
with beet sugar, sweetened with Monck fruit
or whatever the case may be, it is that really
about health or is it about profitability
or is it both?
The companies are in this mode now where more
and more of us are caring about what we put
in our bodies and responding to that by eating
less of their most problematic products, the
companies are responding by cutting back on
their fat, but also adding things to their
products, like protein or fiber, you know,
on the notion that that might help reduce
the cravings we get for those products.
Sugar is really interesting to me.
And I'm, you know, and the science is still
new on this.
And I wouldn't know I wouldn't bet on it at
this point.
But there is concern that this move by the
industry to replace reduced sugar by replacing
it with fake non-caloric sweeteners could
be really problematic.
I mean, think about it.
You know, you taste something sweet.
Your brain is expecting calories, but your
gut doesn't get those calories.
You know, it's quite possible that something
will go haywire with your metabolism.
So, I mean, if you're using a diet soda to
really resist, you know, drinking a full calorie
soda and that works for you, you know, nutrition
was to say, OK, go for it.
But overall, I think it's really troubling
that the companies are moving around the entire
grocery store now trying to reduce the sugar
level, but keeping that sweetness by using
the sweet, sweet baked sweeteners, non-caloric
ones, without us knowing enough about the
science to be really confident in how that's
going to work in our bodies.
Well, that that seems to be the crux of the
sort of nutritionism approach that you can
you can essentially break a food down to a
certain number of calories, grams of fat,
amount of vitamin C or whatever.
And what what you would sort of get to is
a pill that has the same statistics as broccoli.
And assuming that it will do the same thing
for you when the whole food really has something
to it that may be beyond mathematical ID for
lack of a better term.
Yeah, I think that's so perspective and perceptive
of you.
And I'll tell you a story that, you know,
the you know, the nutrition facts box on products,
the label to say the fine print on the back
of a label.
Not all of us can, you know, read it or understand
it.
Right.
I had no idea that that fact box was the creation
of none other than the processed food industry.
Right.
As a way of warding off our concerns about
their products, because in some ways, one
of our basic instincts to love information
is going to be placated when scientists call
this info of horrors.
And and and the reality is when we turn to
that fax box and try to, like, pass out these
nutrient parts of the food, that isn't really
food anyway in the totality, we get lulled
into thinking all that data must be really
great and this is OK for us to eat.
But the nutrition facts box is is is a bit
of a in and of itself.
No, no, no question about it.
The new book out today is Cooked Food Free
Will and How the Food Giants Exploit Our Addictions.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Michael Moss.
Michael, always a pleasure speaking to you.
Great to see you and talking to you, too.